let's talk about this story too also an
exclusive from the daily mail
you know
at least 63 people on martha's vineyard
have tested positive for covet 19 since
barack obama's maskless 60th birthday
bash the most cases on the island since
april so i don't know if all of these
people were at his party to be fair it's
just on the island but the island is not
particularly big
this is this is a great story oh i love
it obama was like i'm scaling back my
party it's still ridiculously massive
celebrities are showing up erica badu is
posting selfies no one's wearing masks
and i'll tell you you
man you could go to church and they call
it a super spreader event you actually
had you know cuomo in new york shutting
down churches this is the perfect
example i mean
i don't understand
how no no i'm sorry i'm sorry i get it
regular people
they'll see the news about black lives
matter protesting in the thousands and
then they're told don't worry
according to the university of colorado
it may have actually reduced the spread
of coven that's right thousands of
people standing shoulder to shoulder oh
yeah because other people didn't want to
go outside but there's literally
thousands of people outside right now
what do you talk
and people see that
i think there's people who love it
authoritarians just love
brutalizing people
and then you have regular people who are
scared of being brutalized
so when they see these stories they're
just like i better just say nothing
otherwise they'll come for me
and that's that's the problem we face
you know when it comes to that
restaurant
uh that was being harassed
they don't want to be politically active
and i can get that i can understand why
but this is your warning man yeah if
you're using american money you're
politically active whether you want to
be or not
that's it's uh you may not want war
about war wants to find you there's
that's where it is ideologically you're
gonna pull up a little bit yeah you can
vote around where we are right now i
think is there was a time where you
could disagree and that was it but now
it's you can't disagree you have to go
along with us it's all about
and also are your ideas so great if you
have to be coercive and impose them on
other people and you can't win with
persuasion and argumentation yet of
course words are violence but actual
violence is not violent i found that if
you you can't if you disagree and just
say i don't believe it no they get
really mad but if you offer a
counterpoint that's very intuitive often
especially in a one-on-one situation
they're receptive to it even but in the
hordes and the masses things can start
to change when you're dealing with
crowds that's a little more difficult
this is a very creepy authoritarian time
right
barack obama announces his birthday
party basically in defiance of all cdc
regulation and they they don't bat an
eye shout out to barack obama for
exercising his first amendment right to
congregate yeah
and that's a job that's right that's
right it's been that way the whole time
though it's rules for me not for thee
and i and i do think at a deep level
it's sort of just like thumbing their
nose at the little people and also by
the way i mean there's so many different
knock-on effects to how this has
increased the power of
what i'll you know cliche use the term
rolling class
like all the major corporations many
major corporations massively increased
their market share during this time
where mom and pop companies got
destroyed you got forced into living
remotely and then using zoom you know a
chinese product of course
but even leaving that aside we're in
this atomized existence where everything
is digital so now you're using
technologies of people who hate your
guts and are going to collect infinitely
more information on you as a consequence
you don't have to be a conspiracy
theorist or not this is just what has
happened and then you know like going
out and oh i'm gonna go on a vacation
wherever i'm gonna have a party mascot
has right you know just before we do put
the mask man mandate in i'll tell you
what it is the elites are
gathering up as much silverware as they
can before the ship the ship sinks right
so we hit the iceberg
there's still some time to get to the
lifeboat they saw that hit and they said
grab as much as you can on the way out
and they're going to grab as much as
they can because that is them running to
the lifeboat before anyone else can and
then leave and see i think it's even
more insidious because it seems like
they're moving our industry into the
these chinese corporations that are
using slave labor and they're just like
whatever they steered us into the
iceberg
they stare us into the iceberg and then
laugh and then jump on the boat and
leave the the the question at the end of
the day is so i think that china is the
greatest foreign threat that we face
although i think that we are we are our
own worst enemy right now if you're a
self-loathing country if you're a
country that says forget about merit
forget about what an individual brings
to the table we're going to divide each
other on a million different bases and
be at each other's throats all the time
and basically celebrate mediocrity as
opposed to excellence and repudiate
everything that we're built on that'll
kill us well before china even gets to
us we'll do their job for them but that
said with the elites
they're now emulating china like they've
kowtowed to china for decades because
they think well if we get entered this
marketplace you know massive profits for
us and china of course has played us
like a fiddle on that count
but now it's more of the emulation of
like the american social credit system
the social credit system with american
characteristics
and the blending of big tech and the
state and using that power together i
think you know you know how i would
describe what's going on with the us
elites and china is kind of like uh you
know a vampire
and this this this guy meets the vampire
and he's like i want the power of the
vampire so i can you know
take power over all the people and
they're like we can grant you this power
but you will be subservient to us and so
these elites are like this is my in
because in china when you're in the
party you're set for life no stress
because i'll tell you this
in america you're on a treadmill and if
you're if you're walking you're standing
still
if you stop walking you'll move
backwards you've got to keep running to
get ahead not when you're in the
communist chinese the chinese communist
party when you're in an authoritarian
regime you can finally sit back and say
i am secure my power within reason you
still have to you know
do work
but man it's hard with competition it is
so hard you know i remember when i was
when i was first starting in in this
industry i had a guy telling me when i
was 25 he was like it's really great
right now everybody loves you and
they're praising you for all the work
you're doing and by the time you're in
your 30s there's going to be some young
kid who develops some new technique and
some new tech and you're going to be
chasing after him and he's going to be
rising and you're going to be worried
about your business going down and i'm
like
well you know we'll see but i get the
idea right the idea that there's always
someone at your heels
so what what these these political
elites both republicans and democrats
are like how do we just finally secure
power in a way we don't have to worry
about it anymore
sell out to china too bad because what
you did was worked harder and then hired
those guys
but what what they're doing is
they're they're they're tired of playing
this game right what do they do every
few years it's phone call phone call
phone call raise money raise money oh
could you imagine i i imagine there's
some like chinese communist guy and he's
like sitting there with mitch mcconnell
or whoever and he's like you know
you wouldn't have to do any of this
fundraising if you just joined the
communist party or made one and they're
in the republican or democrat they're
like really it's like that's right you
would just have the power forever
two-year term what is going on these
people are are in congress for life
after five years they get pensions for
life come on except for the occasional
purges you know where a couple million
get thrown in jail every now and again
that's the only yeah that's that's the
one challenge that they have to deal
with in their system i i agree though
real quick i don't know if that pension
for life thing is true oh really yeah
okay i thought yeah
yeah let's look it up but
i think an element of this is and it
becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy there
is the theory that china is just going
to overtake us and so better to get on
board with china and kowtow to them
because you think that you'll maybe be
one of the benighted party members
someday
however
of course it's those useful idiots who
are the first ones that get lined up and
shot in any revolution and so there's
that and then also on domestically let's
say the the woke ideology overtook every
single institution which it already has
to a large extent but and they really
ended up with their ideal end game
according to their tenants who would
want to live in a country like that the
elites they might be behind 50-foot
walls with private security guards
around them and stuff but like you're
they can't send their kids to school
like how how is your life going to
function so i think it's it's
short-sighted that authoritarian
instinct ultimately is going to end up
in a very
i mean a disastrous situation for them
and their families remember john cena
speaking mandarin that apology it's
pathetic that says everything
these people have already been lining up
at the door for china for the money
you've got the nba you've got the video
game companies anybody who's like i'm
sorry man i i have a rather negative
view of where this country's headed
because it's been decades now where
we've been as ian pointed out sending
away our manufacturing base our industry
the core of this country being extracted
and sent off overseas not just not just
to china but other countries as well and
even mexico that's been happening for so
long
trump tries turning that around to a
great deal and he succeeded in many ways
and they weaponize the media
institutions to
crush it you notice the greatest assault
the greatest attacks on trump usually
came from the national security and
foreign policy and intelligence
apparatus and those were the areas where
he was upsetting the apple card probably
to a greater degree than anywhere else
they really they didn't yes they hated a
million different things about him they
hated him aesthetically i think he
graded on them oh yeah but they also
really hated the fact that he threatened
their power and privilege because he
tried to undo
the establishment progressive wilsonian
however you want to describe it national
security and foreign policy he was a
threat to they perceived him as a threat
to their power and privilege the people
who are voting in
more more of the uniparty and i don't
just mean democrats it's like mcconnell
saying we need more troops in
afghanistan there are a lot of populist
right individuals now who are running
for that we're going to see in the
midterms which is which is really uh
cause her optimism but the uniparty
itself like look the neocons fled to the
democratic party when trump got elected
and then all of a sudden the democrats
became that
tower or whatever i just think it's
hilarious the idea that
you have people voting in their own
destruction while thinking they're not
thinking they're the ones who aren't not
paying attention and it's funny when you
look at the polls independent voters and
republican voters
think the economy is doing bad well i
think by most metrics they would be
correct
the democrats think the economy is doing
fairly good which by most metrics makes
literally no sense unless you're in a
cult
isn't that funny but what the media is
able to do is they're able to point to
the fringes of trump supporters to claim
that represents all of you know everyone
anyone who's anti-democrat or
anti-establishment
is that one small fringe of of the the
die-hard trump supporter you know
and then you get these people that are
effectively voting in their own
serfdom
that's what i think i think it's kind of
funny like in in the end i don't think
i don't think necessarily let me put it
this way i'm not worried
i'm not worried about myself i think if
the country falls apart if we end up
with some you know internal conflict
civil conflict or something like that it
would suck really bad i think china
would then easily just sweep across
crush our allies take over everything
and become the dominant empire and that
seems to be like what will happen
considering what's happening in this
country and i know that i will survive
i'm confident in my abilities i've been
homeless before i'm not all that worried
i think it'll be an adventure but i'll
tell you these people in the cities are
going to cry a deep cry they will sob
they sob they've never sobbed before if
they if they only could see the future
as to what they're going to bring to
their their their countrymen to the men
and women of this nation
man
i'm not going to pretend like a voting
republican gets you out of the problem
either it's like the republicans of the
speed bump the democrats are the ones
setting fire to the building in the
first place so i don't know what you do
but i think when when all the bricks
come tumbling down
i don't know life will suck for the most
part
mostly conservatives will probably be
fine
urban liberals will probably be in very
serious i don't know if that's even safe
to say because if we're really headed
towards what you're talking about
oh okay if you play fallout the theme is
2060 there's a war between america and
china i'm worried about that a nuclear
war then i'm worried about an artificial
intelligence war a robot war where they
have drones flying around patrolling the
skies shooting at anything that moves
people are running from building to
building all over earth
that's very and then no one no human at
that point will be safe that's very
likely if we don't get our
stuff together right now as a race
that is very possible as a future option
we're going that route man
many routes at once but that is one of
them the the drones in the sky
ai seeking out you know skynet and stuff
maybe not too far-fetched considering
what they already have with the you know
the reaper drones and stuff like that
but i i so maybe i don't think they have
enough of them for a country as large as
the united states they can make drones
that can make drones i i if when ai is
working 24 7
and doesn't get tired someone has to
bring in another it's not it's not that
simple i don't know maybe maybe in 30 to
50 years we might have the
infrastructure for for look someone's
got to mine the materials but it ten
years go by and then it's only 20 to 40
years and then
another 10 years go by what have we done
you know when we can solve the mining
problem of how we got humans and sulfur
mines and things like that then there'll
be a big change for the time being it's
a human task
and then you're probably mining
asteroids and then you might have a
self-driving truck delivering the
materials to the a but i don't think
that's that's the issue i think that's
something to be concerned about no i
think the bigger issue is the economy
just crumbles that's the short-term
problem yeah and i'm saying if the
economy if the economy crumbled right
now and you'd go to the store and a
gallon of milk was 100 bucks and there
was like three available and people are
fighting over a can of beans in the
parking lot
i think i'd be fine i wouldn't be happy
i wouldn't be comfortable and i wouldn't
pretend like i'm going to be sitting
atop a throne or anything no it would be
a constant battle for survival when
there's like limited goods and no fuel
but the people in the cities and the
suburbs
they ain't going to be having a good go
but they're going to be in the parking
lot fighting for beans with agnes thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you